we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p you know yesterday i
made a comment about uh donald trump
continuing to misunderstand how tariffs
work and i pointed out when he says we
collected tariffs from china no we
didn't we actually collected tariffs
from the american companies buying
chinese products and this caller
astutely points out that there's
actually another layer to that as well
you said the
[Music]
chinese tariff on steel is paid by the
american company that uses the steel
what you fail to mention is then that
the
tariff is passed on to the consumer so
actually the consumer is paying the tax
tariff that's exactly right and so you
know this is i don't i genuinely don't
know whether republicans understand this
or they don't i don't think trump
understands it my guess is some
republicans get it but they need to they
realize they need to get in line and say
we collected tariffs from china the way
it works is trump put these tariffs in
place to try to punish china let's just
take an imaginary product let's say it's
uh you know
steel for building a car okay um company
says uh we're gonna buy our steel from
china you put a tariff on chinese steel
china doesn't pay it the company if
imagine that for each car you need a
thousand dollars of steel just to make
the numbers easy china still gets their
thousand dollars but then the us
government gets if it's a 10 tariff they
get a hundred dollars from the american
automaker so the automaker is paying for
that steel but the caller points out
something that's important which is okay
initially the company pays the extra
hundred dollars but then they just raise
the price of the car
by a hundred dollars and it is the
consumer in the end so trump brags about
we collected tariffs from china
really you collected tariffs from the
american companies buying chinese
products which they passed on to the
american consumer you collected in
reality the tariffs from the american
consumer not from china and i don't
think trump understands that
but there are certainly republicans who
do understand it but they pretend not to
because that's just the talking point we
got the tariff money from china uh good
good voicemail pointing out how that
actually works on the bonus show today
speaking of prices we're going to talk
about it's not just home prices that are
sky high
rent prices are as well which makes
sense when the price of the home goes up
the homeowner who rents the place will
charge more for rent that makes perfect
sense we'll talk about it we're going to
talk about the 73 million dollar verdict
reached with remington by the sandy hook
families huge legal consequences to that
and we are also going to talk about the
continued drama with alec baldwin after
allegedly shooting and killing uh a
cinematographer
the family of the cinematographer helena
hutchins is now suing alec baldwin uh
we're going to talk about that we'll
talk about al baldwin's cell phone and
there's a lot of
i'm going to start to say strange things
going on here um all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show sign up
at joinpackman.com
to get instant access and we will speak
to you then